الى مجموعه من اخبارنا حول العالم لنبدا
بهذا الكشف الجديد الذي اعلنته هيئه
التراث السعوديه ويقع في جبل الحقون
بمنطقه
بنجران حقيقه هذا الكشف الجديد مشاهدينا
هو عباره عن نقش تذكاري لكعب بن عمرو بن
عبد منى الذي سجل باستخدام اسلوب الرموز
النبطيه ذات القيم العدديه النقش يشير
لصاحبه الذي كان تاجرا مارا بمكان قصدا
موطنه شمال غرب الجزيره العربيه
طبعا علميه في سجل الكتابات العربيه
المبكره جنوب الجزيره العربيه خصوصا من
زاويه تاكيد ان حلقات طور الكتابه شملت
جنوب الجزيره العربيه وليس جمالها فقط
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات